foreign
[Music]
father always said that you are the more
artistic one
have you forgotten you're my twin
brother the the Creator dealt us the
same hand of cards I just played mine
better you missed the funeral I've only
come for the part that matters I will
not share the crown you will never wear
it I've dedicated my life to governor
and the kingdom is on the precipice of
starvation the throne must be mine or
Millions will die have you forgotten
you're my twin brother we are born at
the same time my claim to the throne is
just as valid as yours well I'm sorry
you traveled all this way for nothing
brother I control the city Garrison I'll
have you exiled let us not forget the
power to settle this lays in the palm of
our hands you remember what father
taught us about home combat you dare
suggest what did Father say brother here
in this holy house in front of our
father and the Creator themselves for
the crown to throw the throat and the
lives of millions under its rule I
challenge you you fool you know not what
you do I challenge you to rock paper
cross blades
have you gone insane brother you project
such confidence and yet your eye Quivers
I know you too well but if I can read
you so clearly then how can I win if I
can read the slightest detail on your
face you can read mine we're brothers
see bed of instinct where like weak
sunlight rays of thought or unable to
pierce we are the same you will predict
my every move
poor brother I can sense your fear we
have spent every day of our lives
together you are an open book to me it
will be trivial to defeat you thanks to
my ancient technique I can already feel
him in my mind the moment I pick my move
he'll know for the good of the Kingdom I
must win
one the answer is obvious when I think
about it but it terrifies me too if he's
in my mind I must have no mind I must
eliminate all thought three yes if I
never make a decision he will never be
able to predict me it's
it's perfect father you'd be proud
foreign
it appears we even share similarities in
holy combat
no matter the strategy holds onward as
planned
one two three shoot
again does he know my strategy two
stones in a row what are the chances did
he steal my notes did he follow me into
the archives no
stay the course
don't change a thing the moment you let
a thought enter your head you lose again
one two three
heart screams at me to change course to
throw paper and win but it must not
listen it's my plan too obvious to never
change the shape of my hands not a
conscious thought in my mind if I am to
be the master of this Kingdom I must
start by ruling my mind this strains my
will to its very limited
four rocks in a row
spare us your churlish outbursts other
would be proud neither Prince wavering
in their resolve he still watches us
silently
huh
it can't be
[Music]
ah
mother brother father you yes it was me
he challenged me to rock paper cross
blades
and for the wager
Our Lives the cross blades father lost
his life with the crossed blades the
foolish old man had no idea of my power
and neither do you brother father it's
so obvious I feel like a dollar for not
seeing it earlier we're twins bound to
the same roots of the roadway of the
cosmos
you will only throw Stone it's how he
defeated you and it's how he plans to
defeat me then now that I know his
secret ending this will be trivial
thank you for helping me see father
for the entire Kingdom and The Crown
let's finish this
[Music]
huh
tell me
[Music]
my sons behold the realm which you will
inherit and the noble citizens that
support it each and every one a
subscriber to Corridor digital.com
contributing to the satisfaction and
Enlightenment of citizens and Realms far
beyond our borders
but to reach our goal of total
Enlightenment we must expand our domain
so we must spread the message subscribe
to Corridor digital.com now say it with
me boys subscribe.com
you'll make great leaders one day